foreign
you have no family
you have no friends
you are abused until you gave yourself
now you have a purpose and it is Noble
everything different this time
she's your field agent do what you
think's best I have to be sure
it's able to make contact with the
target
what are her directives then
neutralize the target
Mr President we have a situation
unfolding in real time are you close
closer than we've ever been you're up
from playing outside the line
spiritually do my job man
if your cover is blown there is no
saving you you have to save yourself do
it quiet and you do it clean they care
from poking that there where the target
will be on you
I said his embedded mission is launched
we can't stop it now
home one finds out it'll end up in the
news
this is our mess we clean it up
now
I need you to understand the risks
[Music]
in the risk